you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman chess calm
and I just got paired up playing a 500
game so let's see what we get in this
one
alrighty 45 maybe we could go for uh hmm
alright let's go for a royal up has just
tempted to play d4 there as well
I'd have six ace basics alright let's go
for an exchange in d3 I'm gonna hold off
a little bit on castles to avoid some
line with Bishop g4 and h5
so looking at the c-4 square for my
night and I may want to remain flexible
with my king I may be going Queen side
night c4h three let's go with 94 first
yeah
this is a useful square III
I make a shout just take the bishop back
but they were really quick to Castle
kingside hmm let's start with h3 just
being a little bit flexible I have to be
concerned about the f4 square sensitive
point in my position so I guess in
knight c6 is right around the corner
um you know what let's let's just go in
this direction I go Queen side there's
some tempo gaining moves against my c4
Knight
so what I'm gonna look to do is go for
an F for break let's start with this mmm
maybe I can't get that in so easily
let's go with the night h2 little
multi-purpose move here h3 flight square
a little pocket for my knight and let's
just make sure this night doesn't kill
me cover the d4 square I'm fine with
doubled pawns this is their more
valuable Bishop let's get f4 in right
now start to converge on some squares in
the black position with my knight and
Bishop on it takes okay well
I was not expecting that
hmm I want to be able to recapture on
therefore with my bishop bit tricky to
do all right this is a little bit
awkward I think I have to go to a3
let's see don't have much time yeah I
want to be able to take here because I'm
sensing some pressure against d3 and I
may need to babysit it with this rook
well no I want to be able to defend it
with my Queen rook I don't want to pull
my rook out for the F file oh that's a
strong move yeah that's a really strong
move okay they're preparing to take my
knight and then if I took here they'd
take my night and then recapture on c4
with the skewer so I have a really
really bad structure right now and I
want my knight back in the ball game as
soon as possible
it's not so easy to pull off
be wary of Bishop to c4 I guess we're
just gonna come back
Swiss cheese over here holes everywhere
okay let's get my bishop develops I know
I'm dropping this pawn but how valuable
is he really okay yeah I'm getting
squashed here so let's see this night
isn't playing but neither is my night so
oh my goodness geez okay I guess here
they're playing very very direct very
strong chess aware of every little trick
okay I guess we're go with the Queen to
e2 dropping this pawn now move tough one
okay yeah I guess we're gonna have to
back up
even on time but this is a way busted
position yeah okay let's try and get the
night back involved yeah I don't have
anything here this is a flat-out goner
I'll just play it out a little bit more
I guess
he can fall at any moment not too much I
could do about that okay here and
there's Knight takes f2 rook takes rook
Knight takes h3 or Queen takes rook
mm-hmm yeah I should probably throw in
the towel right around now huh it's just
a bad game yep let's throw in the towel
well that was ugly and got broken down
in the middle game big time 26 mover
okay well let's still go into the
analysis because that's what we always
do even though that was ugly the good
the bad the ugly all shared so in
exchange roll apes' hmm they really got
a timely b5 and c4 break-in that I
really did not appreciate let's just say
I mean night 2 h2 this is the start of
well if I'm playing c3 here
it seems like there's some pretty direct
play c3 Bishop back and now this is a
pretty serious move b5 with c4 breaking
down my light squares this is what I I
mean I need to take care over my light
squares for sure I'm without my light
square bishop but
yeah I also at the same time have to be
cautious of night deform so I don't know
I would not have expected the position
to crumble as much as it did with an f4
move but the issue here is that on b5 if
I go Knight III there's takes rook takes
Knight here and what am i doing about d3
I can't defend that I want to be able to
take with my bishop of my knight is in
the bishops way when he's on the e3
so it's just goes from bad to worse from
this point on kicking off with b5 night
8 3 C 4 is just a strong move
breaking down the light squares and yeah
you saw the domino effect of this move C
for the problem is it takes is met with
Bishop takes Knight pawn takes Bishop
and then a skewer so this is already
lost I know I in the end i'm blundering
a rook but really the issue is is far
back i believe at least as this move
right here
f4 hmm I wonder right around this point
what I could have done better because
from this point on after f4 b5 I think
I'm in rough shape
c4 is just a good follow up
so I
to do something different right around
here is this idea night h2 wrong
altogether I don't think so
maybe at this point I could be capturing
the bishop because what did i do i
played c3 first and then the bishop was
tucked away and now on b5 i have nothing
to take so maybe at this point an
adjustment could be for me to take the
bishop out i'll probably take with the
queen just to still keep some nah keep
the d file open and then maybe i could
live or at least try to live with the
knight on d4 for a bit so this is maybe
a better approach to capture the bishop
before it goes to e7
yeah from there it's just a bunch of
dominoes falling from here I'm on my
heels Swiss like a bunch of holes over
here and yeah it's just broken down
big-time I have to develop my [ __ ] up
and I'm dropping 82 and like to be five
is good they did everything is good from
here
yeah but really the issue is probably
right around here we'll check it out
with the computer of course but maybe a
bit too fast with playing c3 here got to
take that bishop and then go with f4
okay well let's confirm things with
stockfish and see what more we can take
away from this
okay stockfish let's see how bad it
really was going for an exchange royal
apes' taking some care over the light
squares with h3 coming up and really the
thing to question there isn't too much
to question and this one beyond this
point right around here I still think
Knight to h2 is alright
so I'm gonna go with it I want to see if
this is still an okay plan to go with f4
or do I have to still pull it back a
move so knight c6 and then this is where
I played c3 it's not a it's not a top
mova wants to go with a4 or Knight takes
d6 now okay
so with some time it is suggesting the
knight takes Bishop so let's see if c3
is just a game loser
yeah well there isn't a there is a shift
there it does like Bishop to e7 and f4
is no good it's suggesting rook to d1
but this is already awkward no I'd I
wouldn't want to do this because this is
what I'm shooting for this is the way to
get the the rooks working so if this
isn't working then something else needs
to be adjusted so let's just carry out
this capture a little bit and see what
the suggestion is here okay one of them
it did pop up I believe for a moment to
play b3 which has some idea of
preventing c4 I think I do have to live
with the knight on d4 for a bit I can't
be doing this I think the pressure
against d3 this is now a target and the
pressure against it would be too much so
b3 Knight d4 the Queen could go home and
now at least there isn't a quick c4 so
we're seeing the point here with b3 this
would be a desirable move to exchange
off and that's a healthy pawn for a
perfectly healthy one so I could follow
up with Knight takes bishop and then b3
and then still look for this f4 advance
and at least my light squares are not
getting broken down so easily
but after c3 this is a pretty big shift
I mean going from point two ish to
points
six maybe with some time it'll start to
climb as well yeah and this is a problem
and I guess after f4 I'm losing
not quite but it does like b5 as the top
move taking my night and it's no fun
from here
it suggests night to e3 but there's big
trouble with the night on e 3e takes it
wants to go with Knight to f5 the issue
with rook takes is in fact 95
and this is a this is a vulnerable point
and who knows maybe still c4 could come
in the night will drop into d3 yeah I
played Knight a from a3 and it's just
gone c4 is strong yeah nothing to do
here it is lost up to d1 Bishop takes
Bishop take C takes rook takes Queen e7
i played my rook back rook a to d8 top
Bishop III queen takes a and I played
Queen C to night before strong move and
93 strong move I would have thought
Queen takes pawn here I mean you could
do a bunch of different stuff but I
guess Knight to d3 is even stronger
Queen e2 he takes his vest instead of
Knight takes and now Queen takes pawn
Knight f3 and then rook F to e8 top move
you know it's just gone from here I
thought Knight takes f2 but yeah you
could pick your favorite way to finish
me off from here I think takes f2 rook
takes rook there's at least Knight
there's at least Knight takes pawn here
but you have your pick he grabbed the
rook in the corner as well yep it's just
a bad game nicely played by my opponent
to break down the light squares I didn't
really see it coming this b5
and yeah I have to be on the lookout for
this better idea is to grab that Bishop
right around this point
c3 is a it's a disaster Bishop here and
I can't get in the F for break and
without f4 I'm just sitting duck it's
one of those what you have to do you
have to sit and wait there's no
constructive plan no way to expand and
improve the quality of your pieces type
position that was a mouthful but yeah if
I don't have the F for break-in this is
a nothing position for white it's just
no good so I needed to take better care
of this idea of b5 and c-4 stuff but uh
that clearly did not happen taking here
is much better with let's say b3 and
then later shooting for have for okay
lesson learned as usual I hope you were
able to take something away from my
quick defeat and as always I hope you
got something out of it that's all for
now take care bye
you